this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by movement movement
watches was founded on the belief that
style shouldn't break the bank the
watchmakers goal is to change the way
consumers think about fashion by
offering high-quality minimalist
products at a revolutionary price with
over 1 million watches sold to customers
in 160 plus countries around the world
movement watches has solidified itself
as the world's fastest growing watch
company we'll talk about more we'll talk
more about movement later on this show
get 15% off today with free shipping and
free returns by going to MVM t.com slash
Congrats this episode is also brought to
you by the cash app the cash app has
done something very amazing all right
they've introduced the cash card a new
black debit card that you can design
yourself via the app I did it my
producer won fire did it but the cash
card allows you to use the cash that you
keep in the app anywhere you want and
now you have the cash app which is the
best way to pay people back plus the
all-new cash card I'll talk more about
this later on in the show as well
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now
[Music]
so what's up my babies hey guess where
I'm coming at you live from [ __ ]
Australia met a lot of Australian babies
and so far I've been in Adelaide Perth
and I'm in Melbourne now and people say
like some one of my buddies
Tom Green hit me up and he's like hey
not it's not Mel Melbourne its Melbourne
and I'm like yeah but it's got a [ __ ]
R in it so I don't give a [ __ ] so I'm
keeping it real for the for the USA
babies but yeah so I am here in
Australia and I don't know what the
shits gonna be like here because I got
this [ __ ] janky-ass set up I mean
this is a janky-ass setup and I mean I'm
literally on the floor in my hotel room
in Melbourne and it looks pretty janky
but so I'm doing it but it so I had
shows I had shows in Adelaide and Perth
and here in Melbourne last night and I I
don't I don't know if he first of all
let me just say this okay it's very um I
find that I'm I when I'm on the on the
road especially when i'm solo i'm solo
now i didn't bring an opener i have my
my promoter here that I met in in
Australia and we've been travelling
around together and he's great but I'm
solo and I find myself [ __ ] thinking
about you guys thinking about my babies
like walking around looking at things
and thinking oh and seeing oh okay so
that'll be good to talk about on the
podcast or something like that but the
babies would like that and so
I [ __ ] I guess I I understand that
it's a symbiotic relationship here we
need each other but it made me realize
that here all the way over [ __ ] 14
hours away from Los Angeles had that
flights too long make it quicker
make it nine hours or something but it's
14 and every time I [ __ ] do it you're
like I'll go you know I won't you go in
with like an attitude you're like
there's gonna be long you're gonna
[ __ ] crush it do it go to bed go to
sleep so you get there you [ __ ] sleep
two hours go by you wake up and you're
like how long has it been and they're
like - I was might and you're like okay
like Eagle 11 air was left you know I
got for [ __ ] sake um then you sleep
more and then you're like how long was
that and they're like neh got like 10
hours 30 minutes left
you're like oh [ __ ] I slept first
they're my body's betraying me
I only slept for 30 minutes it's not
okay so what's been going on here in
Australia man I tell you came to Mel
Melbourne first well first of all flew
into Sydney then flew to Melbourne which
so it was literally connecting flight
after 14 hours had to get back on the
flight and whoever set that up on fire
because there are for sure direct
flights from Los Angeles to Sydney so I
don't know why I mean there's got to be
right I don't even know but so I did I
did that flight and then I got in and
dude for the first two [ __ ] days I
was walking around like a zombie dude I
met the promoter out here and I had
known him already I met him from in
Montreal when I was there his name's
Andrew great guy
and I was just I don't want to say I was
rude but I was just like when he would
tell ask me a question I just really
yeah yeah that's true or something
because I was tired dude by the way I
looked up jetlag because I want to know
really what the [ __ ] it is because it's
not tough you know it's it's just being
tired dude like I know people are like
well there's a thing that happens to
your body when you're that
for that long there's an overall malaise
you know what how about this you were
just on a plane for 14 hours and also
it's tomorrow now so I'm tired of [ __ ]
jet lag we're just tired maybe just
tired so I would for like two days it
was I mean I was just like trying to
drink coffee oh hey by the way man
Australia everyone talks about how good
Australia is shining coffee is and I've
had good coffee here and but here's the
deal dude first of all in Melbourne at
least there's I mean every other shop
thing is a coffee shop it's
un-fuckin'-believable every other
[ __ ] thing you can get coffee at it
doesn't matter if it's a [ __ ] IKEA
they're like it's like coffee a cafe
it's it's [ __ ] it's Sizzlers coffee
it's unbelievable how much [ __ ]
coffee you can get anywhere but in
America I get an iced americano now
obviously in Australia that's not gonna
be what it's called it's gonna be called
some other [ __ ] because I just feel
like americano it wasn't gonna be
americano
so I [ __ ] asked I got to when I got
to Sydney for connecting I said can I
get an iced coffee because I figured
that would just be normal and I'm like
I'm not gonna [ __ ] get an iced
americano just get an iced coffee and
they say Chris they call me and the it's
this [ __ ] drink
that's beige now I want it black cuz
it's coffee because coffee is black
unless you put [ __ ] in it so did they
put [ __ ] in it I looked and I was like I
got an iced coffee and they're like yeah
that's it and I was like okay
they were like you wanted a latte and I
was like but I ya iced coffee and
they're like yeah is it an iced coffee
or [ __ ] a latte like what the [ __ ]
going on cuz I I still don't know by the
way so I found out what I'm supposed to
be ordering is an iced
long black and now I've been in
Australia for about five days and I'm
gonna look this up on the internet now
since I don't have my computer my my
producer here
iced long black now I don't remember
I've been here for five six days I don't
know if it's iced long black or iced
black long but it's iced long black and
I'm gonna forget that again when I
ordered it next time but basically it
that's what the iced americano is here
so now I'm walking around saying [ __ ]
iced long black like an [ __ ] like I
don't know what I'm saying but every
time I almost say ice black long and
sometimes I say black long and then I
try to think like okay it's not black
long remember that sounds like black
lung and that's a [ __ ] disease that
you get so don't say that once a ice
long black but then I [ __ ] go there
and I'm like wait was it not the disease
thing or the disease thing and then I
say can I get a nice black long and
they're like or a nice long black
whatever the [ __ ] it's called
and they're like yeah sure and then they
do it and they always here's the white
get it together [ __ ] in
Australia they they do it in the [ __ ]
regular hot coffee cup they don't give
you a [ __ ] plastic see-through cop
they literally so it's like now I got to
drink it in four minutes otherwise the
cup gets soggy and it starts looking
like a Salvador Dali painting in my hand
like a moon like the melted clock
[ __ ] you're not I'm talking about
put it in a glass put it in a
see-through cup get it together and look
there's something some good coffee in
Australia but put it in the right thing
huh put it in the right thing I hate
when they give you know when you go to
like Starbucks or some other coffee shop
and they're like sorry we ran out of the
flat lids here's a dome lid ruined my
day
I get it my life's pretty easy you give
me a dome lid on something that belongs
with a [ __ ] flat lid ruined my day I
get it
privileged do your job right get enough
[ __ ] flat lids how about that how
about that how about that isn't that
that Drake song it's annoying when I
sing that but
get a [ __ ] dog don't put a dome lid
on the dome lid put the [ __ ] flat lid
on the fleur-de-lis how about that how
about I don't so how about now that's
what it is
how about now since secure that song you
didn't like me when I was broke how
about now how about now it's insecure
rap is so [ __ ] insecure though for
real remember that song what they've
been they're like we eat so many shrimp
like that's how it starts
I think that's three 6 mafia we eat so
many shrimp like gonna get [ __ ]
indigestion oh really
ed gross so many majendie imagine being
such a mobster and so gangster and like
such and like rapping but being like yo
da we so many [ __ ] goddamn shrimp
we'd better rap about that [ __ ] not for
nothing but we better put that [ __ ]
first we so many shrimp you didn't like
me when I didn't eat so many shrimp how
about now how about now so anyway uh
Australia is cool everyone [ __ ]
Australia's one of those places like
Austin though where everybody's like
dude nobody says anything bad about it
everyone's like dude it's [ __ ]
amazing you gotta go it's [ __ ]
beautiful women great beaches such a
cool vibe and yeah it's good it's good
now granted I haven't been to Sydney yet
and I feel like that's gonna be my
[ __ ] [ __ ] I didn't know there were
that many Asians here in Melbourne it's
unbelievable dude I went to the Asian
area I guess I don't know what it what
it is it's like five blocks of and you
know what the other thing too is like
even though it's English there's another
there's a language barrier like like oh
I [ __ ] asked this guy I was on the
hotel and I was like where's the
elevator and he was like what and I said
where's the elevator and he said what's
that and I said where's the elevator and
he said I'm sorry and I was like okay
we did this three times already I'm very
clear I'm saying where is the elevator
so let me try to say it again and not
make it seem like this guy's a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
so I was like like I didn't want to be
like where's where is the elevator
because then I make it seem like I think
he's an [ __ ] so I'm like okay so I
just said it again I'm like the elevator
where's the elevator and then I realized
and then I just had oh the lift and he
said I was right down there like was
this guy [ __ ] with me come on dude I
understand you're Australian and you
call it a lift but you know what an
elevator is dude if I'm in America and
somebody says where's the lift maybe
I'll say what once maybe but I'll
probably just point where the [ __ ]
elevator is I feel like the guy was
[ __ ] with me there's a lot of it he
was Asian so maybe that had something to
do like maybe he was from not from here
not from even Australia I don't know but
then I went I stopped then I got some
sushi and this guy says the guy who's
making the sushi he was pretty good but
he was like where you from and I was
like I'm from Los Angeles and he says Oh
Jewish people huh and I was like uh II
III don't know and he said yeah and I
was like ah cool and then he showed me
his phone and was like I have a fur the
accent I can't do it he was I got
because he was Taiwanese I came to learn
but he was like I have a friend who is
from that area and he pointed he showed
me his Facebook and pointed on on his
friends profile and then where he's from
and it was it said Colorado and I was
like oh yeah Colorado yeah that I've
been there before he says Colorado
Colorado and I was like yeah yeah yeah
it's it's it's far from where I live in
Los Angeles but you know I was like I
guess there's maybe Jews there I don't
know because I felt like that was the
[ __ ] thing you wanted to know about
and then he was like oh okay
and then he said North Colorado South
Carroll or Colorado and I think he was
thinking Carolina and I was like I yeah
they don't do that in Colorado it's just
Colorado and then I was like what the
[ __ ] am i doing and then I left but
there's like some sort of a weird
language barrier with like lift an
elevator and [ __ ] and some people I
don't know if they're [ __ ] with me
they don't know what the [ __ ] I mean but
like come on guys get with it get with
it
sorry just figuring out this [ __ ]
device here cuz I don't my producer one
fire so yeah so I don't know how I
trailed off I don't know I also don't
have my producer here to [ __ ] get me
back on track so like this is just gonna
be [ __ ] so many tangents here in
Australia so but yeah it feels a bit
like my journal dude you know you guys
I'm happy that the babies are listening
oh and there's gonna be no video podcast
this week and I'm sorry about that
because I don't have the [ __ ]
equipment but it'll be back in two weeks
the video or yeah I might actually do
the podcast Tuesday next week so I can
just do it when I get back as I get back
Tuesday but early in the morning but I
was in oh by the way do it I [ __ ] get
like in Australia I you know you hear
about a few things on a story about how
how great the vibe is how beautiful the
beaches are and how how pretty the girls
are and then you hear about spiders and
kangaroos and I'm like I know I [ __ ]
hate spiders I'm like I know I'm gonna
run into some spider like in an alley
somewhere and the spiders is gonna be
there like hey gallon might and then
there's gonna be like oh you guys
[ __ ] talk yeah we be get over here
yeah you're going you like a Harry I am
you don't see hairy spiders over in
America do you well over we're so
Falconeri we make Armenians look like a
baby I mean such so turned British but
you know what I'm talking about
we I'm like [ __ ] alright one from
Australia yeah
[ __ ] getaway bag [ __ ] back so um
is a gowing almost polite uh hey um so
gonna pull up my hair so um so I'm like
I know I'm gonna [ __ ] see a spider but
then I'm like dude
I'm staying in like hotels and [ __ ] it's
gonna be fine so dude I took a shower
yesterday and I [ __ ] put the towel up
like a good guy like cuz I don't want to
save the planet you know but do you guys
do that or not you know how you can
throw the towel on the floor and they'll
read put it back they'll get a new towel
or you can save the [ __ ] planet and
put your towel and hang your towel up so
they don't take it and you'd and they
don't have to do the extra laundry I
love how they say save the planet
like they'll put a little [ __ ]
pamphlet in your like on your toilet and
it's like hey do you want to use you
want to use a new towel or do you want
to save the planet like we're [ __ ]
Captain America but you know I try to do
my part so if the towel is not to
[ __ ] soiled I'll hang it up so they
don't have to take it and and because I
want to save the planet so um so I put
the [ __ ] towel up and then I and then
I go to sleep well I mean that's not in
that order there's much I did a lot in
between there but anyway these are the
important steps that I need to tell you
about so I [ __ ] hang the towel up and
I [ __ ] go to sleep a lot in between
but then I wake up and I'm gonna take a
shower I wake up I open the shower door
the the [ __ ] the towel is on the on
the door so it opens up I close it I
[ __ ] shower of course I'm in one of
the hotels
hey thirty percent of hotels the drains
are too slow get plumbers hey hey get
plumbers so it's [ __ ] up I'm waiting
now in the [ __ ] shower because min
Hotel in 30 percent of hotels you can't
take more than five minutes shower
without waiting without you
[ __ ] what was that movie with Brad
Pitt and Tom Skerritt whatever that
movie was where they play for fly
fisherman I don't know but anyway so I
turn off the shower and then I go to
grab the towel and I noticed something's
on the towel as I put my face in it and
then I pull it away and it's a [ __ ]
hairy spider dude
I this is this is what I did this is how
I reacted I went I said Jesus Christ and
then I threw the [ __ ] towel in the on
the on the shower floor and now it's
soaked because it's [ __ ] so wet and
it's not draining and I went Jesus
Christ and I said that I think 11 times
walking around my [ __ ] hotel room it
was like in a movie
when you see a spider get in a towel and
you're like spiders don't get in towels
like maybe in a shoe or something around
the wall it straight up got in the towel
and it was gonna attack me dude it was
so [ __ ] scary man and I know it's not
that scary because it was probably a
harmless spider but I don't give a [ __ ]
how about if you have eight legs that's
creepy
imagine a dude with eight legs right oh
but except you're smaller with no face
and you're hairy all over Oh creepy
basically a spider is a [ __ ] guy
that's so [ __ ] tiny and hairy and
then has eight legs and no face oh that
yeah I mean try describe that to a
[ __ ] alien hello
what is this spider you speak of is it
like a human no it's actually well
describe it okay it's about the size of
a thumb Harry [ __ ] has no face and
eight of these legs that I have here oh
my god we are going back to Mars we will
never go back have you heard about these
spiders for spiders
[Laughter]
our spiders like humans so oh so I'm
[ __ ] and whatever that's not even
[ __ ] so they call it soda water not
club soda here that's what I drink but
then I have [ __ ] asked for [ __ ]
soda war and I don't know what it means
it's like oh we don't have and then I
look in the menu and they have [ __ ]
Pellegrino like yeah I'll just get this
and I call sparkling water yeah help me
out you know
help me help you but the shows have been
great man Adelaide was the first time
ever performed overseas and it's [ __ ]
awesome and they do this thing in
Australia where they have an
intermission or an interval they call it
like the opener goes up and then there's
like supposed to be any like people go
to the bar and get drinks for like 15
minutes and then come back and then it's
the main act and I'm like [ __ ] that I
don't do that [ __ ] bring me up but then
the promoter was like well we don't do
that it might be weird for the audience
so let's just have the opener go on and
then and then I'll do it from the booth
and just be like ladies and gentlemen
you know first Australian tour Chris
D'Elia so we did that and I did it and
all the jokes worked I didn't really
have to I changed one thing I guess
there's no TGI Fridays which is a
restaurant in America there's none of
that in Australia so I had to change
that to Sizzlers that's about it other
than that I've been walking around
drinking coffee they tried to set up a
[ __ ] thing where I was gonna go see
the animal reserve or something I don't
know what they date that's what they
called it and I was like is it a zoo and
they're like I kind of and I was like
well what they're like it looks like
open it's like a zoo with no walls or
some [ __ ] oh my god that sounds the
[ __ ] like that'll be the end of my
life oh cool animals with no walls
around them and they can just [ __ ]
rip mARMS off you seen kangaroos bro you
seen kangaroos hey kangaroos have
shoulders any animal with shoulders put
a fence around
I want you there [ __ ] put a fence
around my spider over here it's still in
there by the way there's a [ __ ]
spider in there under the towel that's
soaking wet still and I put make up the
room and of course it didn't make up the
room but it's in there it's living in
there my spider it's probably thinking
I'll get them
but yeah kangaroos have [ __ ]
shoulders dude you seen that you saw
that kangaroo flexin on Instagram that
[ __ ] will literally steal your
girl like without even she wanting to be
stolen she'd be like no no no but the
thing will [ __ ] drag it away I
haven't seen a kangaroo and I didn't
know by the way I had no idea you could
eat kangaroo they got kangaroo burgers
here I'm at I'm a dumb [ __ ] foreigner
I'm the foreigner here
I'm the foreigner here it's weird to be
a place where I'm the foreigner I've
never been the foreigner anywhere a
Canada doesn't count I mean I've been to
Italy and [ __ ] and like Europe but like
that was when I was 19 not as a like
professional adult I'm the [ __ ]
foreigner I feel like a fish out of
water um I don't know but yeah it's been
[ __ ] it's been a while I I kind of
miss home I'm happy that I'm here and
doing this and a lot of the shows sold
out but I do miss home and I feel far
away from my babies even though there's
a lot of Australian babies so you know
let me look at [ __ ] my notes I don't
think I wrote anything down today or
this week because I think I was just
been travelling around but my podcast
yeah these are all the shits from last
week miss my doggies missed some Lots
they're very cute I talk about him in my
act a lot and you know ah singing about
how like cuz I got my dog's new food and
they liked it and I was thinking about
how people are like oh yeah they get
like Alden all natural the whole organic
dog food and [ __ ] and how [ __ ] like I
know a guy who will only get that for
their dogs they're his dogs and he
doesn't want them to eat not that [ __ ]
and it's like hey dude here if you eat
annoying as a human that's annoying
enough if you have a dog he said this
whole thing like I try to not be too
annoying in my life like if I like
eating healthy but I will never be the
guy if everybody orders pizza to not
have a slice of pizza because then
you're the [ __ ] [ __ ]
and you're annoying dude you're [ __ ]
annoying eat this slice [ __ ] boy eat it
up
alright but if you're not if you're like
that fine that's annoying
alright and I got two dogs and I realize
that having two dogs is kind of annoying
so I don't make it annoying right like
some people take their dogs places by
the way I've seen a one dog in Australia
one [ __ ] dog in Australia that's how
to do it man everybody look I have dogs
you don't see me out with my dogs
people ask me do you travel with your
dogs are you [ __ ] insane dude I gotta
go somewhere and I'm gonna bring animals
what
what are you talking about what is this
Game of Thrones I'm gonna bring I'm
gonna travel somewhere and bring animals
dude no I don't care if you caged them
up or not if you have a [ __ ] dog on a
flight you're an [ __ ]
I don't care if it's for emotional
support be stronger I don't care hey
don't cry on the plane leave your dog at
a home I don't care if you're blind cool
that's the deal
if you have a dog on the plane if you're
not blind close your [ __ ] eyes the
whole time and bump into [ __ ] when you
walk
let your dog do it but like people with
their like that's so annoying
I have two dogs I'm not annoying about
them I don't bring them places I very
rarely have brought them to even a
coffee shop you know I'll watch this
watch this dog you can watch my dog
while like no dude you're you know it
reminds me of like smokers like smokers
are so [ __ ] annoying like it's fine
if you're a smoker but when you're like
oh yeah I got to go outside to take a
smoke wait wait for me no no you know no
you missed out I'm going by meet me
there
while you're getting cancer your
prerogative but meet me there
so what was I talking about a dog let me
try to backtrack to see this is what
[ __ ] half so I'm a producer one fire
so dogs being annoying about the dogs
being annoying about something else I
was talking about being annoying about
[ __ ] I'm an idiot and I know a lot you
guys know that you're probably like it's
just that I don't [ __ ] know this
isn't this is just a monologue here
anyway
my whole point is I have this guy that I
know this guy that like only buys like
organic and free-range dog food and I'm
like dude
if I [ __ ] throw up my dog will eat
that my dog will eat a [ __ ] my dog
would eat poison ivy and you gotta get
the [ __ ] dog food
that's like free-range get captured
that's so annoying get captured like
come on dude it's a dog bring do you
bring your dogs when you travel no
because I'm not a [ __ ] circus do I do
I have a bearded lady with me are you
gonna bring your dogs when you travel
when people say to me do you bring your
dogs when you travel I want to look at
them and say do I look like I'm
traveling with a guy who has crab hands
come on man don't travel with animals
don't beat out god chicks with their
dogs I can't go anywhere without my dog
you're horrible oh my god I can't leave
my dog I gotta get my papers to [ __ ]
nah-nah-nah you need extra papers to
travel stay at home ok you know where
your dog should always be where it is
right now anyway
[ __ ] don't travel with your [ __ ]
dog um wait I want to do it like this
actually here and so I want to do don't
travel with your [ __ ] dog me undies
listen you guys got to try these
underwear me undies makes feel good
your butt will be proud to wear
seriously I'm learning right now I wear
I'm overseas they will be the most
comfortable pair of underwear you will
ever own and to check and and to check
it out yourself go to me undies calm /
Congrats
it's tons of styles and patterns to
choose from men and women me undies they
have the perfect fit man for any person
personality for a limited time only
check out me undies first-ever
glow-in-the-dark print I'm going to get
them lights out underwear on but update
your underwear drawer dude and glow at
the same time come on and that's that's
like superhero that's like a superhero
thing me undies also makes socks if you
don't like to wear underwear so you got
no excuse but they're so great I love my
Miami undies I like how they're all
different and how the patterns are
different and it's just cool man like
they or they also have plain ones that
are like blue and grey and green and I
wear those too but it's cool to get a
little funky with it you know if you're
wearing all black and you just want to
you know spice it up a little bit when
you when you lift up the shirt when I
lift up on the shirt on stage a little
bit if I'm doing a joke about a belly or
something and then you know the they get
a little peek at my personality but get
20% off the best and softest underwear
and socks you will ever own free
shipping and a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee go to me Indies
comm / Congrats that's me Indies comm
Congrats wink look I'm not a drinker you
know that if you're a long time baby but
it doesn't mean that I don't like to
entertain and when my guests can have
great wine and I don't have to worry
about what I'm buying I'm happy alright
I'll tell you about a company called
wink they give you access to exceptional
wines from around the world it's very
cool you go to try wink calm spelled T
ry winc calm and take a brief palette
profile quiz and wink will recommend
distinct and interesting wines
customized to your palate and will be
shipped directly to
every month I mean it's so easy wink
basis the wines they send on your taste
preferences but yeah I mean I was at my
house and people were there the other
night and we had plenty of wine to go
around I got compliments on it and it
was great and there's no membership fees
to which I hate you can skip any month
cancel anytime
and right now wink is offering my
listeners if you're a baby $20 off your
first order when you go to try blink
comm / Congrats that's try wink spelled
T ry winc comm / congrats to get $20 off
your first order now try wink try wink
comm / Congrats movement I talked to you
guys a little bit about this movement
watches was founded on the belief that
style shouldn't break the bank and the
watchmakers goal is to change the way
consumers think about fashion by
offering high-quality minimalist
products at revolutionary prices it's in
there in a hundred and sixty plus
countries I got to watch it too awesome
I got one of those it's all gold and it
makes me look like a boss a baller and
but but it's they're inexpensive I
really like the design I get compliments
on it actually whenever I wear it and
these start it's just 95 dollars at a
department store
it'll be like 400 500 bucks so it's it's
really a good deal they they cut out the
middleman and and and and there's no
retail markup and so it's got they got
the best possible price because you go
check it out it's over 1 million watches
sold in over 160 countries so they
obviously know what they're doing don't
miss out but you get 50% off today with
free shipping and free returns by going
to MVM t.com / Congrats this watch has a
really clean design that makes a great
fashion statement they really do they
all do go look now is the time to step
up your watch game go up to MVM
t-dot-com / Congrats join the movement
like I did so yeah so don't buy dog just
your dog eats [ __ ] literally ok your dog
eats [ __ ] you know people are like amen
eat [ __ ] and they don't mean like
actually eat [ __ ] dogs do that though
dogs do that though okay anyway so I get
home soon
Halloween's coming up huh hey how about
the fact that if your [ __ ] you know god
this bag is just driving me [ __ ]
crazy dude keeps blowing over here so uh
when where that spider is at this point
I you know what I feel a little bit like
when I'm doing that podcast on my own
is and not with my producer one fire is
uh is I feel a little bit like Bear
Grylls like I'm like here we are when
I'm out in I mean Melvin and I got like
I think easier is he sound like that
does even accent I think it does I'm all
the way up in the 11th floor this hotel
I'm just hunkered down I'm trying to
fall into something heat gotta go in the
minibar see what they got they got
cashews if you're lucky enough you've
want some cashews maybe some other [ __ ]
that people would never heat unless
they're in out dowel room anyway I was
lucky enough to find a pillow and put it
down here I got my podcast think
recordist plugged in there's a spider in
the bathroom should be okay he's under
old damp towel um so uh I do feel like
that but because I'm literally on the
floor right now cuz I need to have this
[ __ ] thing plugged in my producers
like hey man easily you know we charged
the thing it's fine and I every time I
get to where I got to go and I got to do
a podcast remotely it's never charged
ever one fire and this much does have a
bad battery life or something but anyway
I don't remember what I was going to
talk about but I'm always surprised I
can talk for longer than an hour though
on
[ __ ] podcast I watched [ __ ] Wonder
Woman on the flight over and also that a
new Planet of the Apes movie dude I
watched that planet Apes movie man and
how about the fact that did you see that
one it was the one with Woody Harrelson
first of all the first 20 minutes are
[ __ ] awesome okay there's like this
fight scene and all these gorillas and
[ __ ] and apes are like oh my god it's
amazing how much I really look and then
it for like 50 minutes it's the the
movie is only about the Apes and only
one of the Apes talks so it's like a
[ __ ] silent movie and they're just
looking at each other and they're going
home
oh actually the one that it was a cool
movie okay I'm not bashing a movie but
the one thing that was annoying about
the movie was that they they show tried
to in your face it about how hey these
Apes are basically human like we did it
dude like we get we get the point dude
there were so many scenes where that
where two Apes would look at each other
for way too long and like all emotional
and [ __ ]
and you were supposed to think oh it's
cool cuz that's what humans do you know
like oh wow like they hold each other's
faces and [ __ ] and but it was like okay
you know and there was music playing and
it was like disabled just look at it I
get it I get the scene can we go to the
next thing can I see Woody Harrelson
trying to [ __ ] find these Apes but
yeah so much about the about the about
the Apes and and and [ __ ] and then one
and then like they weren't like but it
was funny because they weren't like they
were like they literally was like we're
like oh oh oh like that's what the ape
would do that's what it would sound like
oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh it was like
they tried to make it like you did you
know that they told the people who did
the voice acting that they were like you
know what
definitely don't ape it up because we
want the Apes to be more human it would
just be like oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
it sounded like they were just [ __ ]
coming Oh
oh god oh my god oh oh I swear one time
to a plane oh god yeah all over all take
it take it
ah you don't like those Disney movies
where they would have like a [ __ ] a
sultan with a boner like Guinness
[ __ ] either like what's a Aladdin or
like what's the one with the [ __ ]
Ariel like there'd be like a quick
[ __ ] shot of like a sultan with a
boner the flux is Sultan anyway you know
Sultan all I know is they wear crazy
[ __ ] like cool [ __ ] like wow how dumb do
I sound I don't know what a sultan is
somebody in charge of something you know
but yet I have like a [ __ ] Sultan
with a boner on the [ __ ] on the
Disney Channel and [ __ ] and that's like
the artist thing they think that's funny
and then every time they see [ __ ] the
movie Sultan with a boner they seize
every time they see a movie Aladdin they
see a sultan with a boner
anyway definitely said Sultan with a
boner way too much
oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh that was what
one of the Apes did dude watch the new
Apes movie and it's doing that and then
I also saw a Thor no not Ragnarok that's
the new one I saw Thor whatever the [ __ ]
it was the Dark Ages or some [ __ ] it's
probably called Thor the Dark Ages
because why not but I like that Chris
Hemsworth and then I saw Wonder Woman I
can't watch like real movies on the
plane like I try but it's just like
they're never as good as they are when
you can so I got to watch like [ __ ]
action [ __ ] I gotta watch it works like
Oh
mm-hmm
and so whatever I have [ __ ] two shows
left in Melbourne and then five in
Sydney which I had no idea but that's
way too many
and then Brisbane and then home and Ohio
then I go to Ohio let me do these other
ads and then I'll [ __ ] do all their
questions and [ __ ] mm-hmm tracker wallet
phone keys wallet phone keys every time
I leave the house it's like the world's
biggest scavenger hunt I hate it I try
to put everything down in the same place
I even have a place for them but I don't
do it I don't do it I always lose
everything but eight years ago tracker
changed everything in that situation and
it's it's very cool it's his company and
they they released their first tracking
device eight years ago and now they've
done it again with their all new tracker
pixel with tracker pixel you'll never
have to worry about losing your things
again
charcoal pixel is the lightest Bluetooth
tracking device on the planet a place
tracker pixel on whatever you tend to
lose your keys your wallet whatever for
me it's my dog's small enough to fit
anywhere when you misplace an item that
has a tracker pixel attached you use
your smart phone and a 90 decibel
Willard will help you find it in seconds
it even has powerful LED lights so you
can find anything even in the dark
locate your item even if it's miles away
because every tracker user is part of
the largest crowd locate network in the
world it's very cool and trackers 30 day
money-back guarantee means you truly
have nothing to lose these things are
really cool they're really small and and
and very cool-looking go to the tracker
comm / congrats to get 20% off any order
that's the tracker th e TR ACK are.com /
congrats for 20% off the tracker comm /
Congrats no e in there on the second
part square cash every
switching to the cash app because it's
the best way to pay people back friends
family co-workers anyone Australians
Americans Canadians Sultan's sending and
receiving money is totally free and fast
and most payments can be deposited
directly into your bank account in
seconds here's how it works you download
the square cash out link to your debit
or credit card select an amount to send
and type in a friend's phone number or
email address to complete a payment
they'll get a notification they've
received the money and that's it no
gimmicks Square cash is cool because
it's not a social network I hate that
the other guys there it's like a social
network you'd be like yeah I paid Tom
for sushi that's so annoying who wants
that I mean who wants that
so this cash card isn't that they have
is a new black debit card that you can
design yourself via the app I saw
somebody else designed it and they got
it and they wrote it CUDA on it which
was hilarious and it's a true baby the
cash card allows you to use the cash
that you keep in the app anywhere you
want you'll get notifications for all
payments that made with the card
directly to cash up so let me see your
cash card make it and tweet it to me
you can laser at your card to
personalize it and it will be delivered
directly to you for free it's like
another credit card but it's way cooler
the cash app team is constantly building
awesome new features so what are you
doing using the other guys get cash app
today
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now all right yes so I don't
know you know I don't know what I don't
know what to do here because I usually
have my producer tell me I'm we're not
gonna do an Elder today and we probably
won't do one for next week but we are
going to do them when we get back I have
some guys in mind you guys have been
really doing some [ __ ] cool [ __ ] and
to show that you go above and beyond the
[ __ ] being a baby in the baby
fellowship so I have I have I'm looking
through my instagrams and I don't
remember which ones I done I done and
haven't done
but I already did that one I was the one
with a guy who had the [ __ ] sitting
next to the girls with the tits I think
I did that one and guys scarf is too big
okay let's do this one cuz this one I
[ __ ] love and I even liked it a long
time ago and nobody hey guys it's time
for the most [ __ ] up Instagram post of
the week oh gunk this is a really short
and sweet one dude and this one makes me
[ __ ] laugh dude and let me just tell
you it's because up one letter that's
why this is the most [ __ ] up it's to
grant post of the week okay so Wow
actually I'm looking at this guy's
profile okay so this guy is a guy he
looks Indian and he is pointing to his
temple but it looks like he's not
pointing to it looks like he's doing it
like hey I'm thinking like it's not like
he's like hey that's my temple it's like
he's like thought he's like thinking
thoughts hey smile nice looking fine
fine looking guy nice nice smile there
kind of a smirk one [ __ ] sentence
under it and this got most [ __ ] up
Instagram post of the week because of
one letter okay this is what the caption
is when thoughts overtakes you when
thoughts overtakes you say wait it sick
foreign hey man just write it in your
language man it's all good nobody's
going to judge you
thoughts don't overtakes you thoughts
overtake you and because of that s dude
I [ __ ] saw it and like dude I was like
rolling around on the ground because it
also the way the guy looks he's just
like so happy and [ __ ] when thoughts
overtakes you also it's not what
thoughts overtakes you it's when you're
taking a selfie and that's it when
thoughts overtakes you you take a selfie
and you point to your temple now you
just someone doing something dude
so funny like what's going on you know
man it's loud outside why I don't even
know what's going on here I guess
there's a new everyone sweetie there's a
new Jean Claude Van Damme movie coming
out or something which is pretty awesome
I'll definitely see that let's see oh
man
why do I love [ __ ] up [ __ ] like that
when thoughts overtakes you a good thing
congrat see I can't how you spell
congratulations I'm trying to look up
these hashtags pod here we go there we
go there we go gonna look up see it's so
much he's really my producer man but
okay here's one Ben Guzman at Ben Guzman
people who aggressively leave 1 to 2
seconds early at the crosswalk when
there's a gang of people waiting on the
corner I guess he wants my thoughts on
that bro
[ __ ] [ __ ] that man that's awesome leave
go get it go [ __ ]
go [ __ ] the people dilly-dallying in
[ __ ]
so annoying move
my god now this is a great tweet to me
at Savannah briar for at Savannah
underscore briar hey Chris Leah how do
you feel about this like she knows how I
feel about this this is why I like this
this is a sign that [ __ ] says I mean
who makes this [ __ ] dude who makes this
I'm gonna read it first if the sign says
I'm not just an ant oh a UNT obviously
I'm a big cup of wonderful covered in
awesome sauce with a splash of sassy and
a dash of crazy all for [ __ ] sake dude
dude to think that they sold some of
these I hate when people [ __ ] say
well that's me I'm crazy like for it all
of this sucks first of all if you say
awesome sauce I know I had the thing
about the [ __ ] Wendy's thing - saw
some sauce or whatever the [ __ ] that's
stupid but this is everything awesome
some people say awesome sucked like hey
I'll meet you later awesome sauce like
uh I want to [ __ ] punch my own face
over and over again but I'm not just an
ant first of all yeah yah I'm a big cup
no you're not a cup you know big cup or
small cup because not cutting human of
wonderful first of all uh this is done
because it says I'm a big cup of
wonderful covered in awesome sauce
so no dude you don't cover a cup you
fill a cup on the big cup of wonderful
filled with awesome sauce there that at
least is less infuriating but now you're
just a cup covered in awesome awesome
who says awesome sauce with a splash of
set when they when they describe
personality traits like ingredients I
want to [ __ ] jump off a boat dude and
a dash of crazy you're not crazy dude
when people are like ah that's just me
I'm crazy I was watching a little bit of
the Power Rangers movie and in [ __ ]
20 minutes the the [ __ ]
one of the guys is just like they're
like are you crazy and he's like yeah I
am and he's not he's just a [ __ ] high
school student you know being crazy is
awesome if you get there you get to call
it it's just like a black dog you don't
pretend you're a [ __ ] black belt you
don't put on a black belt if you're a
yellow belt bro if you want to call
yourself crazy earn it and [ __ ] [ __ ]
in your pants and leave it there and
start yelling about the government you
don't get to be a - a crazy
you get full-on crazy dude when people
when people say that's why oh that's why
I always say like whenever you you never
see somebody that's kind of crazy you've
never seen somebody that's kind of crazy
you always see something that's yelling
about religion when the world's gonna
end or the government's doing something
wrong you never forget hanging out with
someone in there like what was that did
somebody say something and you're like
what and you're like I'll never mind
must have been my mother minimum brain
that's a little crazy
you never heard somebody say that [ __ ]
you don't get to be a dash of crazy
you're the whole [ __ ] thing and
you're not covered in awesome sauce if
you say awesome sauce you're not awesome
and if anybody calls themselves sassy I
mean how annoying is that person oh I'm
sad I'm a sassy person that's why that's
like when somebody when a girl says like
I'm a [ __ ] whatever or when a guy's
like or when a guy is like I'm not a
dick I'm just honest nah you're a dick
hey that's just me man nah oh that's
just you dick when they use it as under
the guise of being honest um yeah
[ __ ] awesome sauce bro uh
[Music]
I just realized that my TV's been on the
whole time so hopefully hopefully you
don't hear that in the background uh
okay
you coot a baby at turnaround could dunk
well we know that that guy's a fan of
the podcast but uh what about people
stocking shelves at a store and then
actually start whistling you know I
actually talked about this with my
brother all the time if you're whistling
you're an evil villain if you're
whistling I'm sorry about the
construction it started again I can't
believe I got such a I think I did this
podcast during their lunch and now
they're doing jackhammering again so I'm
gonna wrap this up soon but when if
you're stocking shelves at a store and
then if you're whistling period
Ian evil villain didn't I talk about
this before whoo whistles who [ __ ]
walks down the street is just like the
[ __ ] are you doing yeah I used to have
this I I got I broke out in hives once
when I was like in high school and I
went to this allergist to see what I
would I was wrong to me I had to go with
him a few times never figured out what
was wrong a bunch of [ __ ] and paid
him a lot of money to do nothing so he
would like do tests on me and and he
would just be like
mmm he would hum and it wouldn't here's
the thing that pissed me off
he wouldn't hum a song he would just hum
notes like bro if you're gonna be an
annoying [ __ ] oh and hum especially when
you're in somebody's face doing them tat
doing tests and [ __ ] if you're gonna hum
alright that's one thing but if you're
gonna hum hum [ __ ] a song you know
I'm like you know that [ __ ] Aerosmith
song how about how he sings dude you
know could there be more s-sir rock star
way to sing bending the notes and [ __ ]
[Music]
miss you babe I don't wanna go to the
bathroom
unless you coming with me baby do watch
me dunk um and I'll be missing you baby
I don't wanna go to the store unless
you're coming with me do wanna meet you
anywhere [ __ ] [ __ ] what a [ __ ]
don't want to close my own Oh what dude
you also you're not like that like this
guy didn't [ __ ] millions of chicks like
come on dude who's an Aerosmith who was
the lead singer yeah you do you're doing
it's fine and you don't miss you you
know what was I talking about though oh
yeah he would hum not a song he would
just hum notes and it took me like a
visit or two to realize like he it's not
a [ __ ] song this [ __ ]
literally got the audacity to be
annoying but not [ __ ]
do it in the confines of a song
this guy is an allergist and he's gonna
just sing notes bro who are you [ __ ]
Bach you know that [ __ ] was like no
don't sing notes put it in a song make
it I don't even care if it's an obscure
song it wasn't do it he'd be like mm-hmm
that guy who hums
look if you're a guy who whistles you're
up to no good you're plotting a murder
you're plotting a [ __ ] huge disaster
if you're a guy who hums you're gonna
get shot soon in a movie that's what it
is
normal day that's who you are in the
movie yeah dude so don't if you're gonna
whistle just group you you're an evil
villain but if but if you don't huh if
you're gonna hum I'm a [ __ ] song dude
anyway that's a good thing to end on you
[ __ ] babies do it thanks for
listening man for real
I is real hard to do this podcast
remotely but I do it for you guys and I
also do it for my bank account just so
you know because make money when I do my
podcast
so remember movement watches get 15% off
today with free shipping and free
returns by going to MVM t.com / Congrats
square cash have you switched yet
download this free square cash app
design a cash card get it for iOS or
Android now subscribe and rate and
review the show tweet me at congrats pod
or using the hashtag congratulations pod
I hope that you're enjoying the video
episodes on youtube video episodes go up
Thursdays at the latest but there will
not be one this week and I'm sorry about
that I'm still for what the idea of
releasing it next
week on Tuesday I'm the new one but
there may not be one for next week as
well as well but upcoming shows they're
still Melbourne left well I don't know
it might be that's tonight so I might be
sold out or done or whatever but still
come Sydney Brisbane Columbus Ohio
Irvine San Jose Winnipeg Calgary you
gotta get quick on that Calgary show
it's almost gone the Winnipeg one adding
another show because the first one sold
out really quickly man on fire watch it
re-watch it like it or whatever you do
on Facebook now I don't know if that's
what you do enough Facebook on on
Netflix but yeah Chris Chris Lea calm
tickets and you guys are the [ __ ] and
remember man if you're gonna hum hum a
song all right I I miss you babies but
it's nice to see you Australian baby
[Music]